how excited are you for the SNL skits
every Saturday I mean I'm excited for
those kids every Saturday
yeah yeah it's been kind of interesting
I texted my brother back in May saying
you should call Lauren and you should
talk to him about oh wait wait
Trump on yeah playing Trump on Saturn I
love and I sent him the screen save of
that exchange because I still had it in
my thread in my phone I sent it to him
we should be thanking you for all of you
I kind of wish I kind of had the idea to
very early they give the press gives
Tina Fey credit for it but I said
seriously if it Lauren won't go for it
you should go to like you know you know
like The Colbert Report has like it as
like a reporter out in the field like
what Samantha bees die should you should
just have fun that do it a couple times
you should play Trump and here we are
today but I I am having a blast with it
my brother Stephen knots not as much but
he's I'm hoping he's enjoying it so for
people who don't know there was a bit of
a Twitter exchange that got a little bit
heated about it um I don't think it was
heated I grew up in a rowdy rambunctious
Irish Catholic look every day or the
days like everyone think Billy gives you
know brother Stephen a Smackdown am I
Stephen tweeted that my father who was
it was a veteran would be upset with the
way the press is treating Donald Trump
it was more of a roast you know I got
audition Punk'd I just really yeah I
just said I just said my father who I
didn't like him referencing I don't mind
if he references my father but don't
create the illusion right that my father
would have liked or respected or
supported Donald Trump at all
he was as left as they come I mean
bordering on like a social democrat and
for him to to just to create the
illusion that my father and I just had
to let the public know and I said if Dad
were alive today he'd smack you upside
the head for supporting a goon like
Donald Trump yeah so this was Medicare -
what oh no we all doin brother please
really please you should see the text
exchange just between my brother Alec
and Steven and my brother Steven wait
it's down your Berta Lee Thanksgiving or
Easter Christmas like at your house oh
oh that's a little personal okay
are you kidding you know it's reading
these it's weddings and funerals now we
all get together for weddings as you
know yeah Thanksgiving and Christmas
everyone's married everyone who has the
in-laws everybody's doing their own
thing they'll be toasting we live in
California so we're seeing them over the
summer during the vid but talk about
anxiety talk about mental health issues
you get my family together for in the
beginning when I met her family with all
of the like China's parents divorced
when she was two and Michelle lived with
Warren Beatty she lived with Jack
Nicholson she married Dennis Hopper yes
she was good friends with Mick Jagger
yes when I told Chyna that I had the
same parents and I lived in the same
house and I went to the same school
system my whole life she went into the
kitchen and she rolled up a piece of
Reynolds Wrap into an engagement ring
and she proposed we were together we
were yes we were together for like four
or five Munch's like please marry me I
told her my dad was my Cubs that's what
happens got later I said my father was
my cups mastery and my little league
coach I said my father ran the Cub
Scouts when we were all I guess she's
like you liked me very much yes no I
thought like her family was the crazy
family but here we are 20 years later
and my family has jumped the phillip
shark and we are as we are now like it's
gonna be what does what makes you guys
amazing yeah it's gonna be you know a
photo finish or he's the crazier family
for sure